warning the video you are about to watch
contains scenes of cringe and bad
storytelling your discretion is advised
stop ah what the hell you hit the kid
again I will shoot you in the face oh my
god I can't believe this is an actual
scene and let me tell you it gets worse
hey everybody I stumbled upon this show
the passage on Fox and it is literally
the funniest show that's not supposed to
be funny
you're gonna want to stick around for
this one maybe pop a few pain pills down
a ball tequila because I'm about to
break down this pilot and show you just
how insane this thing is here we go you
crazy bastards so the whole premise of
this show is that a deadly flu is
threatening to kill most of the planet
so these researchers travel to Bolivia
in the hopes of locating a legendary 250
year old man that can somehow help cuz
you know members of the CDC don't have
anything better to do with their time
than to look into old bolivian folktales
and then for some reason they're
accompanied by like a military team to
find an old man but hey it actually
works because they find this golem dude
they keep trapped in a cage and they
they let them out try to get away from
the cage okay we're less than 2 minutes
in and we're already getting some big
logic problems remember these guys are
here because apparently this thing
somehow has a cure for the deadly flu
what did they do
they shoot the living crap out of it
three years later Zack Morris has
graduated from Saved by the Bell and
explains that he's with project Noah a
government agency on the brink of
finding a cure for all disease a drug
that makes people immune to disease
infectious diseases like aids Ebola SARS
SARS
what is this 2003 oh by the way his real
name in the show is Brad but [ __ ] it I'm
gonna call him Zach anyway so they get
this guy on death row to be a test
subject for their science experiment
because you know that doesn't break any
ethics laws at project Noah the
scientists sit around in this big
boardroom with videos of people dying in
the background and explain what's going
on for all of us dum-dums
we could try incubating in mammalian
veera cells no that would take too long
you need extended passage in with an T
triptych activity
oh yes the ante triptych activity why
didn't I think of that
anyway we find out that this Chinese
avian flu is quickly spreading leaving
the scientists with about three months
until it makes its way to the US how do
they know it's gonna take three months
science I guess and apparently the only
solution to figuring out how to cure
this disease is through these vampire
creatures but in order to synthesize a
cure they need to test it on a kid so
they do the only logical thing and
kidnap one Zack Morris and Lieutenant
Kid slapper we'll get to that in a bit
go pick this girl up and oh god just
listen to Zack talk to this girl about
her mother's death I'm agent Doyle this
is Brad wool gasps hello Amy we
understand your mother died we're very
sorry for your loss
hello Amy I am a normal human who cares
about your loss I will not kidnap you
now this is where things start to get
real good Amy bails in the two men chase
after her and watch this
the dude straight up slap sir what picks
her up over his shoulder and one dude is
like hey what are you doing with that
girl
so they toss her in the back of the car
then my favorite we doing why we stop Oh
what the hell you hit the kid again I'll
shoot you in the face see this is how we
know zach is gonna be a good guy he's
the child abductor with a heart
Zach calls his boss it explains that
there were like 10 witnesses who saw
this whole kidnapping in broad daylight
and the boss just says don't worry we'll
take care of it Wow like this don't even
worry about it
then Amy gets carsick so they pull over
in broad daylight where a she can just
run or be yell for help for God's sakes
they're in the middle of downtown back
at project no it's nice to see they gave
these vampires some nice foliage to
spruce up their cells so this doctor guy
is just chillin watching his old friend
cuz I guess that's what you do and out
of nowhere this random guide comes up to
him and tells him he's having nightmares
about him who is this guy
I mean like maybe he's the guy who
cleans the windows cuz he has a rag here
anyway it's just like he was randomly
put here to explain that vampires give
nightmares and it's lunchtime coming
back in the car they pass a carnival and
this is so unbelievable they've just
kidnapped a girl about an hour ago and
they decide to make a pit stop at their
carnival the girl that is supposedly
going to say Millions and they just
decide to stop for some fun and games
watching YouTube and now stopping at a
damn carnival she's cargo yeah kids slap
her over here is right but Zach ain't
having it and goes off to play a rifle
game with Amy because you want to give
the girl you just kidnapped a rifle also
a carnival is like the most populated
area and worst possible place to be if
you've kidnapped someone by this time
her face would have been all over the
news and a carnival is the last place
you want to be so Amy nails the shot and
zach is like holy damn holy damn it who
says that yeah go get your prize sweetie
what in the actual hell he's Dell asking
all the carnival goers if they've seen
this girl you kidnapped her you're
supposed to be keeping a low profile now
you're making
scene and asking everyone if they saw
her oh my but you're gonna love this
so his phone rings and he just leaves
her like straight up leaves for a minute
this is the worst kidnapper ever he
doesn't even have eyes on her she could
just go up to someone and be like I've
been kidnapped but I guess not
so on the phone is Zach's ex-wife and
she drops this bombshell I feel like I
need to move on and maybe have another
baby because you know this is a
conversation you have in your parked car
and surprise surprise Amy didn't leave
I mean hey she's got a giant
inconspicuous unicorn no one's gonna
find her now so Zach's partner comes
along cuz I guess he was just like on
the ferris wheel for an hour and tells
them that they have to go he goes to
take a slash and instead of Zach just
leaving with Amy he comes in and rear
and chokes him Shh this is what you get
for being bad at your job oh and he also
takes his wallet
now Zach and Amy are really on the run
not only by the cops but by this
organization that hired him in the first
place so they send his best friend to
take him down and we learned that Zach
killed 98 people in Afghanistan who is
this guy Rambo and we find out he likes
this girl because it reminds him of his
own a daughter he somehow felt
responsible for killing so he decides to
take her out in the forest in the
pouring rain and in any movie where
someone kidnaps another person and takes
them out into the forest it's usually
not a good thing but he thinks it would
be good for her to take some time and
say a memory about her mother because
you know it's not like they're on the
run or anything and we have time to do
all this they stopped at the gas station
where we finally see that there's a
nationwide manhunt for our main
character anyone happened to be at the
carnival yesterday so he immediately
gets in his car no wait what are you
doing you're using the payphone oh god
damn it so he calls his ex just to tell
her he's made mistakes and guess who's
now filling up their tank when he gets
back to his car a police officer you
just had to take that call didn't you he
surrenders saying that if they go to the
police at least the bad men won't get
them like why didn't you just do that
before anyway gets taken into custody
the man who is wanted for kidnapping and
they just let him chill there beside the
girl he kidnapped
they don't even bring him to a cell or
anything in fact they cuff him
to a chair that's not even bolted to the
ground in literally less than 30 seconds
after he voluntarily surrenders he says
make up your mind Amy goes to steal the
keys of Zack can uncuffed himself and
the sheriff rightfully turns his gun on
him but rather than shoot Zack just
continually gets closer and manages to
take the gun right out of his hand this
is like the worst sheriff ever woody
oh and here's another gem of a scene
they just like friggin rip into him Zack
and Amy run into a side room and just
check out his cute little stance here I
was half-expecting screech to come
around the corner
[Applause]
Zack fights off some dudes and randomly
opens a drawer to conveniently find a
clip of ammo like what the hell how did
he know there was a Moen there why is
there a mo in there none of this makes
sense so they're about to make their
exit when they're stopped by the main
bad guy and the writer here commits the
biggest sin a writer can do deus ex
machina basically when some external
force happens that helps the character
in some way and what is the deus ex
machina here when all looks to be lost
for our duo some random sparks go off in
the background allowing Zack to shoot a
fire extinguisher concealing his way out
but like seriously look how pathetic
this fire extinguisher is I can't see
and here they are making their getaway
while the dudes with the automatic
weapons don't even fire at the tires or
them or anything so the episode ends
with Amy and C by the Bell driving off
into the distance and we discover he's
shot now I did put myself through the
torture of watching the first 10 minutes
of episode 2 and it gets even more
insane as a gunshot wound at Zack man
just to get on a school bus full of
children by faking that amy is his
daughter who is apparently new to the
school are you actually kidding me god
this show is great ok so I didn't win
but I've got the new serial of the
champs screeches
thanks for watching everyone smash that
like button and make sure to subscribe
and leave a comment below more videos on
your way so get that Bell on so you can
be notified as soon as I come out with a
new video and remember daddy loves you
very much